bal à papa mon
salut tout le monde
vous avez vu comme je suis beau
extraordinaire n'est ce pas et si vous
voulez des nouvelles de ma santé tout va
très bien je suis de bonne humeur et je
sens bon je me suis vidé ce matin une
bouteille entière d'autres colonnes sur
la tête
que julie et françois ne sont pas là
quand j'y pense oui ils ont dû aller au
port pour l'attendre way qui met maison
et la grande photographe de mode vous
vous souvenez celle qui est venue
l'autre jour photographiée monsieur du
snob et léona en bébé eh bien elle
revient aujourd'hui ni alors cette fois
je suis là et prêt à être photographié
bonjour casey mais à bonjour france
qu'est ce qui se passe mais oh là là
mais tu as tu as mis un costume
aujourd'hui un costume que tu crois ah
ben oui c'est vrai bien gérée par
marquer est ce que tu me prends pour la
b si la nounou qui signa jetaient sur
nenon que tu veux prendre ma place et te
faire photographier par zoé et ben je
l'admets pour une fois mais aussi ça
m'aurait fait plaisir d'avoir ma photo
dans un journal oui eh bien il suffisait
de le dire
nous pourrions posé ensemble c'est vrai
que c'est mieux tu veux bien tu ferais
ça aussi c'est très gentil n'a pas
marqué je sais c'est complètement idiot
de vouloir sa photo dans un journal
tourner quand même peut pas s'empêcher
d'en avoir envie hein
de toute façon nous ferons a pas plus
beau duo comme monsieur du snob et
léonard à difficile aux
eaux
quel choix retenu vous avez là alors
vous vous êtes bac es avec votre charge
ayé vous révoqué vous de moi
ça m'est égal rira bien qui rira le
dernier
qu'est ce que tout ça veut dire c'est
très simple ma vanité m'a poussé l'autre
jour me faire photographier par cette
demoiselle jouer et je les bien payé
puisque je lave où j'ai été ridiculisé
mais cette fois j'ai mis ma tenue en
taiso et voit la paille costumes et tout
décoiffé elle voudra jamais se faire
photographier jeunes même s'ils disent
'non' que vous n'avez pas tellement tort
moi dans ce que c'était mais je suis un
petit peu ridicule
je ne suis pas certain non plus que ce
foulard my bien où est trop tard mes
amis trop tard zoé sera là d'une minute
à l'autre et vous n'avez plus temps
allez-vous changer d'ailleurs ne vous en
faites pas elle vous apportera vos
costumes
je suis ravi de vous voir bel enfant
vêtu de noir
je ne suis pas un enfant je suis un gros
éléphant
quelle est cette femme exquise
qui savoure des cerises
c'est un marchand de charbon qui
s'achètent du savon
que j'aime entendre à l'aube roucouler
cette colombe
c'est un ivrogne qui boite dans sa
chambre sur le
3me ta main dans ma main tendre je
t'aime oh ma fiancée
je ne suis point où votre science
je suis une vieille et je suis pressé
allez laissez moi passer
attention
part ça c'était beau comme ça va
maintenant regarder vers les ballots
regardant les ballons mais ça la voix
parfait
formidable
voilà a placé une magnifique quand tu
vois c'est bien mieux dans cette tenue
j'avais bien raison de vous faire
changer ça va mieux si puisque hors
sérail
je sais j'avais été complètement clio de
me changer ouais moi il faudrait
peut-être songer à photographier mais
oui on va aller en place aléatoire bon
comme ceci au nom là là c'est ridicule
tu as l'air d'un éléphant qui marche sur
des oeufs vont d'accord attendait comme
cela alors non ça va pas mieux écoute
les miens il faut que tu bouges c'est
comme ça que tu auras la nature à
blesser une marche ce 6e facile à dire
casimir j'ai une idée chante nous ta
chanson vous verrez il dans une session
très amusant magnifique on fait comme ça
d'accord elle aimerait bien d'accord
alors musica
[Musique]
avec une chanson
imagination
je vous en mets dedans repris une copie
du bonheur tranquille
ne soyez pas terrorisé
je suis le monstre du pays
je m'appelle casini
la bombe couleur orange
sont aussi économiques
si l'on me dit maladroit
que moi
je sais jouer de la musique
je suis né est ce matin camille si
j'aime la glace pour son choix c'est
pourquoi c'est mon droit
avec une chanson et un peu d'imagination
[Musique]
je vous emmène dans notre it is
du bonheur tranquille
[Musique]
ces couleurs rencontrer ne soyez pas
terrorisé
je suis le monstre qui fait rire
je m'appelle casimir
j'ai une
machine est une idée fantastique
je mens jeu gloubi boulga
mais je danse ça m'a
gêné la campagne
de cocagne où sim et même aux cadres toi
c'est mon droit c'est mon droit
ap culte aux chansons
imagina
chaque sommet du temps d'autres ici le
au pays du bonheur en pis
silver compris
ne soyez pas terroriste
je suis le bon ce qui fait rire as
je m'appelle casini
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce que j'ai froid moi tu n'as pas froid
toi fais pas choqué ce qu'on pourrait
faire pour se réchauffer bien fait comme
moi tu te bats les flots comme ça ah bon
ça s'appelle se battre défense
mais ça fait mal dit don et non pas du
tout nos freins informations c'est très
bon pour la circulation du sang mais tu
connais pas autre chose pour se
réchauffer un jeu alors un truc plus
marrant tissot ont recours est joué
attends à l'attaqué de la diligence par
les indiens pour se réchauffer mais on
aura fini j'en attends c'est vrai ça
entretien tiens voilà tout à
[Musique]
mais côté que du coup on n'a qu'à se
dire que tout a c'est la diligence
alessi a tout à y
croire et et à monture sinon grand club
à des rocheuses planté flèches
empoisonnées dans sa carapace ou
n'ai pas le temps de rien mais si nous
laissons passer j'ai des courses en mer
doit pas passer toi me donnait au nord
est de dire des bêtises de gesticuler je
me suis blessé trois villes encore tu
dois me donner ton armé je n'ai pas de
temps pas puisque tout un tas d'items
pendant
six ans habite blanc est évident qu'elle
juste stupide
moi je pose ma flèche empoisonnée au
bulgare
voilà on est un coin qu'est-ce que j'ai
un aux bulgares ont pu ramener du
honduras est un poison très très violent
cas toujours froid 10 mois un peu oui ça
j'ai froid alors je vais faire
travailler des ménages à la menthe
fraîche au fait tu vas proxy d'anti
desquels sont les flèches que tu connais
à part celle des arts que attend y
suivait la plaie les flashs des panneaux
indicateurs ensuite ensuite j'en connais
pas d'autres il n'ya l'expression filet
comme une flèche ça veut dire partir
très vite il a lancé des flèches qui
veut dire lancer des choses désagréables
ou jean avec sa langue
tu me suis avec sa longue on peut pas
lancer mais sinon comment plan s'est
lancé des flèches c'est à dire des mots
pas gentil puis la flèche qui est le
point culminant du clocher de l'église
et puis la flèche de la charrue et puis
là où il ya du vent d'hier du vent qui
se lève à leonard si j'allais chercher
mon cerveau lent ah oui tu sais ce que
c'est clos devant lio nar anon
levant ce sera pour un autre jour
aujourd'hui mon sujet s'était les
vents
alors alors alors venez ne vous en
faites pas c'est la zoé arrive dans une
minute coûte que des nuls à présent très
très bonne mais ne marche pas jamais
elle voudra faire une photo de moi
c'était ta et pour un journal
monsieur je vous attends ja faire des
photos de vous vous avez vu dans quel
état je suis mais c'est formidable je
n'aurais pas pu rêver mieux en place
monsieur donc attention à ce risque avec
ça non ne discutait pas est passé lui le
bras autour du cou
mais ce n'est rien il ya toujours des
petites puces qui pas là dedans c'est
voter pour naïve qu'elle ne bougez vous
ne voulez plus vous avez des pauses
extraordinaire
voilà ça sera la faute aux vedettes de
mort par town avec écrit en dessous les
deux épouvantails de l'île aux enfants